okay so fifty cubits at G so this one's
all about entering turning intrigue it's
early
okay little before complicating the
others maybe me so here we go okay so
it's another one where he must have a
bit more time for me it's kind of like
the middle of something the first movies
for me to move at 90 degrees to if I can
do that I agree to be quicker I fall in
the loop let's angle still so I see is
he's got some time he's coming to me so
we'll open our I think you about there
so Feeny I use is I'm escaping here only
this is a shield doesn't she contact
from here attorney to cut he brings he's
back forward with his front flip while
doing it in that way it also makes the
whole thing more consistent doesn't
happen now I push forward here will be
tentative so you take its or perhaps
okay but he picks up on that really
pushes back then pieces
you never cut through it though I though
that thick now I carry the cut down here
okay no in the end of these cut my head
looks completely open he comes up the
strike Isis the hurry that the
[Music]
so the middle point of the cubic tachi
is first all variation as I moved
forward Eevee he stopped winter and why
do i disengage this also as he steps
forward ice I saw my first body
variation we boot my glutes aside and
cut he now moves in the car
and he moves in our movie underneath in
here and he simply forwards across my
back occasionally needs a bit of speed
to do there again the four zones bands
it looks it looks very loose not too bad
[Music]
13:10 variation so good body variation
for this center point Eddie and I push
forward the edges I also need to pick
this up around
trollese elbow for this middle position
I might push forward he starts the move
to pop up under occasionally hey you
very similar to the second assault
variation okay so that's the fifth Cuba
touching this concludes the qubit FG
sophistication it's quite challenging
but fun as well so I hope you enjoyed
this one and hopefully the rest of the
series thanks for watching
[Music]
you